Evet
şimdi Efendim Bu benim ikinci tedex
konuşmam
o ilk konuşmamda bana demişlerdi ki
Sakın bu kırmızı çemberin dışına çıkma
sen çok hareketli sin demişlerdi o
zamanlarda hareket Leydim beceremedim
sürekli şöyle sahneyi dolaştım bugün
mecburen çemberin içinde yer alacağız
şimdi gücünü etkinliğini ve saygınlığını
kanıtlamış bir organizasyon tedex ve
kırmızı çizgi Koleji de Antalya'da
gücünü saygınlığını ve itibarına son
derece kanıtlamış iki tane kuruluşun
ortak organizasyonunda sizlerle birlikte
olmak sizlerle sohbet etmek benim için
hem çok keyif verici birşey hem de çok
heyecan verir o nedenle teşekkür
ediyorum davet edenlere kırmızı çizgi
kolejine ve salona baktığımızda salonun
büyük çoğunluğunun ve kuşağı olarak
adlandırılan yaş grubuna dahil olduğunu
görüyorum Şimdi Z kuşağı olunca ister
istemez bütün ve bunların odağına
dijitallik dijitalleşme teknoloji sanal
gerçeklik Efendim metta World şunlar
bunlar şey yapacak eklenecek Ben tam
tersini yapacağım dijitalli
önemsemediğin için değil sakına yani o
artık çağımızın gerçeği ve ona dikkat
etmek zorundayız uyum sağlamak
zorundayız kullanmak zorundayız ama
Benim sunumum da Tamara dönemlerine
gideceğiz mağara dönemlerinden bugüne
kadar hayatımızı etkileyen bu günümüze
yansıyan Gerçeklerden söz edeceğim ben o
arada şiir okuyacağım Eğer yükleye
bildiği isek videoyu şarkı dinleteceğim
ve bu sunum bittiği zaman aklınızda ve
gönlünüze şöyle bir tat bıraksın
istiyorum Biz insanız birlikte yaşamak
zorundayız ve
bu birlikte yaşamak için de birbirimizi
anlamak zorundayız duygusu size
yerleşirse ben Amacıma ulaşmış olur biz
şimdi eyvallah
şu kumandayı çalıştıramadım ama
bu ahçı eyvallah
ya Neyse siz Yardımcı olursanız
sevinirim oradan şimdi milattan önce 350
yeryüzünün yetiştirdiği en büyük
filozoflardan bir tanesi diyor ki Aristo
Bugünlerde gençler kontrolden çıkmış
durumda da kaba bir şekilde yemek
yiyorlar yetişkinlere karşı saygısızlar
ana babalarına karşı çıkıyorlar ve
öğretmenlerini sinirlendiriyor lar diyor
bakın Bunu söyleyen anneniz babanız
değil Bunu söyleyen yan komşunuz Cemile
teyze değil Bunu söyleyen kendi
gençliklerini Unutup da size ayar
vermeye kalkışan öğretmenlerinizle değil
otobüste yer vermediğiniz için
sinirlenip söylenen bir amca değil Bunu
söyleyen yeryüzünün tarihin bugüne kadar
yetiştirdiği en büyük filozoflardan bir
tanesi
2372 yıl önce söylemiş bunu Demek ki
2300 12 yıldır yeryüzünde değişen bir
şey yok yetişkin kuşaklar yaşlanan
kuşaklar kendilerinden sonra gelen
kuşakları beğenmiyorlar
bu kadar
Dolayısıyla orada bir sıkıntı varsa
sıkıntı yetişkin kuşaklarda Çünkü
beğenmedikleri gençleri onlar
yetiştiriyorlar
bu patlatabilirmi slayt a peki eyvallah
olmadı mı
13. slayt a istirham ediyor rica
ediyorum ve basit bir soruyla devam
etmek istiyorum izniniz olursa insan ne
için yaşar
Keşke zaman ve format uygun olsa
karşılıklı sohbet edebilsek ama ben şu
yanıtı vereceğim çok basit insan mutlu
olmak için yaşar siz bana bir sürü şey
söyleyebilirsiniz de başa Çok sağ olun
Teşekkür ederim başarılı olmak için
yaşar şu olur bu olur insan temelde
mutlu olmak için yaşar Az önce gençleri
yerden yere vuran Aristo'nun bir sözüdür
mutsuzluk ahlaksızlıktır demiş ama
Mutluluk nedir dediğimizde de mutluluk
kişiden kişiye değişir efendim yani
sizin vereceğiniz yanıt Başkadır sizin
vereceğiniz yanıt Başkadır Sizinki
Başkadır mutluluğun kriterleri farklı
fakat gerçek olan şu var Biz bir
aradayız birbirimize mahkumuz O nedenle
değil bu Yalnız bir varlık olarak
yaşayamayacağı için Yalnızlık Allah'a
mahsus demiş büyükler O nedenle de mutlu
olmak için birilerine muhtacız Fakat o
birileri en yakınımızdaki ler bile en
sevdiklerimiz en kıymetli lerimiz bile
birbirimizden o kadar Farklıyız ki ki
Can Yücel'in çevirisi olan bir şehri
paylaşacağım sunumun sonuna doğru o
kafalardaki farklılıklar ister istemez
bu mutluluğu etkiliyor Peki nasıl
etkiliyor bir adım İlkadım diyoruz
birbirimizi anlamak için anlamak
zorundayız Çünkü uyum içinde yaşamak
istiyorsak Yani bu kuşak farklılıkları
kuşak çatışması bir gerçek mi Evet
gerçek bir kaç somut örneği üzerinden
devam edeceğim Ama sonuçta Bunu ortadan
kaldıra bilmenin yolu birbirimizle
toplumla uyum içinde yaşayabilmek
hepimiz buna mecburuz yetişkinlerde
mecbur genç kuşaklarda mecbur Ama bunun
ilk adımı fotoğrafta gördüğünüz Bu
armuttan elma gibi kokmasına Üzümden Muz
gibi tat vermesini beklememek Bizler bir
arada yaşamak zorunda olan farklılıklara
sahip kuşaklar ız Dolayısıyla bu
kuşaklar ilk önce birbirlerinde ki
farklılıklara tahammül etmek hazmetmek
zorundalar ama
hazmedemeyenler de kimler
hazmedemeyenler de genellikle yetişkin
kuşaklar bakın
Burasıda istisna değil Şimdi böyle çok
Engin hoşgörüyle Ondan sonra sevgi dolu
bir biçimde konuyu anlattıktan sonra
stop dediğinde perde indiğinde sahne
ışıkları kapandığında İçinden bir
canavar çıkabiliyor bu İTS kuşağı
denilen benim de dahil olduğum kuşağım
hemen bir öğretme Arzu hemen bir
yönlendirme arzusu hemen bir Emir verme
arzusu Dolayısıyla bu Evet evet gerçek
Peki bu kuşak çatışması kuşak çatışması
diyorlar da kuşak dedikleri şey ne belli
tarihlerde doğmuş belli toplumsal
dönemlerde doğmuş Dolayısıyla aynı
şartlarda yaşayan aynı sıkıntıları
çekmiş insan grubu insan topluluğu şimdi
diyelim ki ben 1970 doğumluyum
25 yaşında önüme takoz gibi bir makine
koydular bilgisayar bu dediler bunu
öğrenmezsen dediler bir şey yok ben 25
yaşında bilgisayarla tanıştım Benim 26
yaşında cep telefonum oldu Biz sokakta
oynuyorduk yetişkin insanların çocuklara
zarar verebileceği gibi bir duygudan
yoksun olarak büyüdük biz yetişkinler
zarar vermezdi çocuklara şimdi sokağa
çıkamıyor çocuklar sadece ekran başında
yaşamlarını geçiriyorlar ister istemez
değer yargıları değişiyor Benim annem
babam ayak bir iki üç senede bir gördüğü
için ayakkabı eskidiğinde kızarlar da
niye öyle şey yapıyorsun diye
Dolayısıyla ister istemez Bir önceki
kuşak bir sonraki kuşu anlamakta
zorlanıyor ya işte anne baba telefonumu
eski de modelini değiştireceğim
dediğinde e yazmıyor mu telefonu mesaj
gönderemiyor musun konuşamıyor musun
noktasına geliyor ya da toplumda Durum
kötü ekonomi kötü falan dediğinizde
sokaktaki Dayı diyor ki çıkar telefonunu
göster diyor ve kuşak farklılığı
dediğimiz dünyayı algılama öncelikler de
ki farklılık bu değer yargısı farklılığı
O nedenle de efendim Peki bu kuşaklar
nereden geliyor dediğimizde uzun uzadıya
şu kuşak bu özelliklere sahip olan deyip
kafanızı ütüleme yiyeceğim zamanda ona
müsait değil Benim buradaki temel amacım
bu kuşak farklılıklarından kaynaklanan
çatışmalar
hayatımızı nasıl olumsuz ne diyor ve biz
bu olumsuz etkileri nasıl aşabiliriz
onun 5'te Buyrun sessiz kuşak dedikleri
Bir Kuşak var aşağı yukarı
1927 45 doğumlular Efendim bebek
patlaması kuşağı Baby boomers dedikleri
1945'ten 65'e kadar olan bir kuşak sizin
büyük çoğunluğunu Z kuşağının en çok
anlayan kuşak Z kuşağının da en iyi
geçindiği kuşak Baby boomers kuşağıdır
neden biraz sonra söyleyeceğim öne geldi
planlama dın biçimde diyeceğim ki
anahtar bu kuşak çatışmalarını önündeki
anahtarlardan bir tanesi empati dir
başka insanları anlama girişimi anlamı
özelliğimiz Fakat bu kuşakların
hiçbirisinde Z kuşağı hariç empati yok
bu empatiye en çok sahip kuşak Z kuşağı
bu ve beybi Burslar zehirlere en çok
anlıyorlar Neyse oraya fazla şey
yapmayalım girmeyelim bu kuşakların
hepsinin dünyayı farklı farklı algılama
farklı farklı yorumlama biçimleri var
yani işte efendim siz bir yemek
masasında iken ailenizle yemek yerken
cep telefonunuzu arkadaşınızla
mesajlaşırken
Babanız anneniz ya da deden izniniz bunu
saygısızlık olarak nitelendirilebilir bu
saygısızlıkta bilgisi yok ama onlar öyle
görmüşler
Dolayısıyla ister istemez her kuşak
beraberinde farklılıkları da
barındırıyor bunu gidermenin Bir Yolu
Var Ama önce fark kendisini nerede
gösteriyor dedim ya Yani dijitalleşme
dijital dijital teknolojileri
kullanabilme sanal gerçeklikle haşır
neşir olma son derece önemli ve biz
bunun dışında asla olamayız
olursak sistem biz iyi bakın dışına iter
ancak farklı dijitalleşmede zaten bu
dijitallik kullandığımız kelimelere
yansıyor ve sağ yeni kuşaklar daha genç
kuşaklar
barda ha kısa konuşuyorlar ne haber bro
diyor mesela
anne baba da diyor bro neymiş video
doğru dürüst konuştu yapsana Ne yani o
öyle anlaşıyorsa erbur oturur Eyvallah
bitti kanks naver diyor Kanki sevgimi
falan ya senin
anneannesinin ahretlik dediğin insan
babamın dost dediği insan artık kanka
diyoruz biz ona Kendi istiyoruz yani
bunu Bıkmadan usanmadan sabırlı anlatmak
lazım anlayacak mı hayır anlamayacak ama
yine de anlatmak lazım şimdi fakat
dijitalleşme önemli Eyvallah ve neden
önemli çünkü
mı bugün
bu genç kuşaklar işte y kuşağının
sonları
1990'lardan sonra Doğan Z kuşağı mm 2020
gibi Ve şimdi Alfa diyolar 2020'den
sonra doğanlara bu insanlar dijital
Dünyanın içine doğuyorlar bizim asla
hakim olamadığımız biçimde şu araçlara
gereçlere Hakimler tek bir tuşa
bastığında dünyanın herhangi bir
yerindeki
akranlarının nasıl yaşadığını görüyorlar
Dolayısıyla tek tuşa bastığında mesela
Almanya'nın bizi kıskanmadım mı görüyor
bu kuşaklar Almanya'nın bizi Kıskanma
Adımı görünce ister istemez anasıyla
babasıyla delisiyle ninesiyle çatışıyor
O senin bildiğin öyle değil diyor ve
böyle olunca ve bu nokta geliyor
dayanıyor Buyrun size kuşak çatışması
yaşayıp ancak burada bir nokta var
dijitalle çok fazla boya onların dijit
bu anladıkları ne mesela ben de eksik
uşağıyım dijitalleşti dijitalleşti
gidiyoruz en çok anladıkları dijitallik
sosyal medyada Facebook ve Instagram
kullanımı Annelerimizin babalarımızın
dedelerimizin elleriniz odaya arkadaş
toplantılarından fotoğraflar ya aile
fotoğrafları işte oluşumu mezuniyet iki
çok şükür kızımın nişanı gördük falan
diye yedikleri içtikleri sizin gibi
kullanmıyorlar sizin gibi
kullanmadıkları içinde değer yargıları
farklı anlamıyorlar a Fakat bu
tehlikeyle barındırıyor dijitalli çok
kullanırsak dijital obezite dediğimiz
bir sorunla karşı karşıya kalıyoruz
nedir dijital O mesela ben obez bir
insanım yani vücuttaki yağ kitlem boyuma
göre fazla birazcık son iki buçuk üç
senedir evde oturmanın getirdiği bir
şeydi bu rahatsızlık nedeniyle ama
Sonuçta o bizim yani beden bu ya kitle
sinek ne oluyor dijital obezitede bu
beyninize gereğinden fazla bilgi
yüklerseniz ki dijital dünyanın en büyük
tehlikesi bu dijital obezite oluyor
insanlar Peki çok basit bir kaç soruyla
Siz dijital obezite misiniz dijital obez
misiniz lütfen kendinize Kendi kendinize
benim bu yanıtları Burada en az üç tane
soruya Evet diyorsanız dijital obez olma
tehlike niz var trafikte toplantıda
Arkadaş ortamında sık sık telefonunuza
bakıyor musunuz
bu EGO sörfü yapıyor musunuz Ne demek
EGO sorfu diyelim ki bir paylaşımda
Bulunduğunuz Instagram'da ya da
Facebook'ta sürekli Bakıp beni
beğeniyorlar mı paylaşımı beğenmişler ve
kaç kişi bakmış Takip ediliyor mu
diyorsanız size ko sörfü yapıyorsunuz
demektir ve Efendim sık sık
fotoğraflarınızı paylaşıyor musunuz ya
da tıkın malı izleme yapıyor musunuz Ne
demek beğendiğiniz diziler vardır
diyelim ki bu diziyi oturup internetin
başına soluksuz iki günde 4 5 sezonu
bitiriyor musunuz ya da bir bilgisayar
oyununda takılıp 4-5 saat Tuvalete bile
gitmeden Bilgisayar oyunu oynuyor
musunuz
tuvalete giderken de telefonu yanınızda
götürüyor musunuz yanıtlar evetse
dijital basınız Geçmiş olsun o arada ben
özellikle bu rahatsızlığı geçirdikten
sonra ben de dijital O bizim ama bundan
kurtulunca herhalde onu şey bu peki
burada Einstein Einstein iyi bir fizikçi
drama fizikçi iliğinin ötesinde çok iyi
bir filozof tur diyor ki insan ruhu
teknolojiye yenilmemelidir dijital like
çok kafayı ararsak teknolojinin
bağlanması olursak ruhsal ve bedensel
sağlığımız tehlikeye girer ve Dijital
Dünya ile çok haşır neşir olan
İnsanlarda bir depresyon eyleminin çok
fazla olduğu görülmüş tespit edilmiş iki
narsistik eylemler Kendini çok beğenme
kivir eğilimlerinin arttı görülmüş
Efendim Peki ne olacak
bu
Murathan Mungan Türk dilinin en iyi
şairlerin den bir tanesidir
benimle yaşıt buradaki dizeler ölü bir
yılan gibi yatıyordu aramızda
yorgun kirli Ama umutsuz geçmişim Oysa
bilmediğin bir şey var sevgilim ben
sende bütün aşklarımı temize çektim
diyor benimle yaşıt bu dizelerde ben
şunu anladım kuşak çatışmaları
aşılabilir hiçbir duvar açılmaz değildir
nerede anladım bu dizeleri bana 19
yaşındaki bir kardeşim hatırlattı bundan
3-4 sene önce ya dedi Siz Murathan
mungan'ın biliyor musunuz Bilmez mi Adam
benle yaşıt benden birkaç yaş uyuya dedi
böyle bir şiir vardır o zaman anladım ki
düşüncelerin beklentilerin isteklerin ve
önceliklerinin ayırdı dünyalarımız kuşak
farklılığı diye duygularla birleşe
biliyor ve duygularla birleşiyor
dediğinde bu salondaki gel bu Dişlerimin
büyük çoğunluğunun ya duymadığı
bilmediği ya daha biliyorum diyebileceği
birisinden bahsedeceğim yine duvarları
aşabilecek birisi dünyada dünya
radyolarında şarkıları en çok çalınan
Türk şarkıcısı biliyor musunuz
bu Selda Bağcan vakti kötü kullanmamak
için şey yapmayayım Selda Bağcan benim
bu yine çalışmadı mı Yardımcı olur
musunuz
hiç beceremedik
bu Eyvallah bakın
bu ses şey yaptım çıktık
Biraz dinlen sonra bilgi vereceğiz ve
[Müzik]
bu çocuk kim
abone ol
ne
[Müzik]
güzellik ya
bu
yeter satıyorum bak bir şey yapmayalım
slayt dönebilir miyiz size zahmet
olmazsa
o da adlı gibi koşuyor zaman orada şimdi
Selda Bağcan 78 yaşında
Ah ah
78 yaşında Selda Bağcan sessiz kuşak
yani Baby boomer falan da değil Bizim
gençlerimiz onu bilmiyorsun İşte o
gençlerden şikayet eden anne ve
babalarının kabahat edilir Selda Bağcan
Bugün dünyanın en ünlü rock
festivallerinde en çok sahne alan ve
hala sahne alan Türk şarkıcısı dır
Barselona da Berlin'de Danimarka'da
Londra'da y kuşağının ve z kuşağının en
sevdiği festivallerde Alaçatı'da ot
Festivali nde utandılar artık
Barcelona'ya gidiyor Londra'ya gidiyor
Danimarka'ya gidiyor biz de çağıralım
diye Peki Selda Bağcan bu şarkılarıyla
Az önceki türküsü de Mahsuni Şerif'in
bir türküsüdür Selda Bağcan ünlü
yapmıştır o türküyü Selda Bağcan mesaj
Yüzüklerin Efendisi adında Efsane bir
film vardı Bundan yıllar önce onun
başrol oyuncusu ikinci fotoğrafta el
yahut bu müthiş bir Selda Bağcan
hayranıdır ve yine
PlayStation oyunlarının en ünlülerinden
bir tanesi Skate u Skate 2 bu oyunun
zemin müziği Selda Bağcan'ın Bu size dün
ettim türküsüdür moncef adındaki dünyaca
ünlü rap şarkıcısı
düzenlemiştir Bu oyun için bu türküyü
Dolayısıyla kuşak çatışması Evet var mı
var birbirimizi anlamakta zorlanıyoruz
bu zorlanıyoruz değer yargılarımız ve
önceliklerimiz farklı farklı ama bu
aşılmaz mı hayır aşabiliriz dediğim gibi
duygular bizi birleştiriyor bir sonraki
slayda geçebilir miyiz peki bunun adı
nedir ilk adımı empati bir minibüs
anlayacağız fakat biz birbirimizi
anlamıyoruz birbirimizi gömüyoruz
Herkes bizim gibi düşünsün istiyoruz
özellikle burada daha ileri kuşaklara
söylüyorum gençler kendileri gibi O
değil de kendileri gibi inanmadığın da
kendileri gibi yaşamadıklarını da
çatışma başlıyor aşağılama başlıyor
Eyvallah o zaman Empati yapmak lazım
empati kime yapılır mesob Bir Müslüman
bir müslümana empati yapıyorsa bu empati
değildir Müslüman ateist empati yapması
lazım ya da başka dinden birisine
yapması lazım Bir kadındı kadınla empati
yapıyorsa onu empati falan değildir
kadının erkeğe Fatih yapması lazım ya da
erkeğin kadına empati yapması lazım
bizim gibi olmayan bizim gibi düşünmeyen
insanlar anlarsak ancak uyum içerisinde
yaşayabiliriz bir slayt atabilir miyiz
size zahmet yok bundan sonraki ikinci
adımda da Vinci'nin Şeytanları adında
bir diziden alınmıştır o fotoğraf o
dizide izlemenizi öneririm diyor ki
Leonardo Da Vinci istiridye diyor
dolunayda diyor ağzını tam açar diyor ve
yengeç diyor ağzını Tam açan istiridyeli
bu durumdan faydalanmak için
istiridyenin içine Yakışık bir taş
parçası atar ya da bir yosun atar diyor
ondan sonra istiridye ağzını kapatamaz
diyor yengeç değiştireceği afiyetle yer
diyor ve buradan bir sonuç kısa
çıkartıyor ders çıkartıyor ağzını çok
konuşmak için açan insanlar diyor
mutlaka diyor çuvallarla Vardı bizim
empatiden sonra İkinci nokta dinlemeye
ihtiyacımız var birbirimizi anlamak için
dinlemeye ihtiyacınız var Efendim
İkincisi de bu sonra Can Yücel Usta
rahmetli çevirmiş Gerçi ateist rahmetli
denmesini istemiyor değilim ama rahmetli
diğerini öyle denir ölenlere en uzak
mesafe ne afrika'dır ne Çin ne Hindistan
ne seyyareler uydu dmx yarı ne de
yıldızlar geceleri ışıldayan en uzak
mesafe İki kafa arasındaki mesafedir
birbirini anlamayan yani yaşla kuşakla
şu bu da değil birbirimizi anlama çabası
ile ilgisi var bunun ve tırtıldan
kelebeğe doğru gidiyoruz Bir değişim
hayat dünya değişiyor hepimiz
değişiyoruz bu değişime en az anlayan
insanlar yetişkin kuşaklar Ben de
onlardan bir tanesi
Dolayısıyla burada bizim eğitimlerde
tersine mentorluk dediğimiz bir şey
yapmak zorundasınız annelerinize
babalarınıza dedeleriniz annelerinize
Onlara bu değişimin olduğunu Siz
öğretmek zorundasınız nasıl derseniz
anahtar belli iki tane bir empati kurmak
lazım İki dinlemek lazım bitiriyorum
haddini fazla açmayın 1-2 dakika geçti
bile demiştim ki konuşmanın başında
insan ne için yaşar demiştim insan mutlu
olmak için yaşar demiştim Sonra da
mutlulukta insanlara bağlı demiştik
Fakat burada bir nokta var bize
genellikle ne anlatılıyor buradaki
büyüklerimiz bu Eğer söylüyordu
annelerimiz babalarımız öğretmenlerimiz
başarılı ol başarılı ol başarılı ol
başarı ölçütü olarak tane veriliyor ve
güzel bir okul oku doğru dürüst para
kazan Saygın bir işin olsun güzel bir
kadınla yakışıklı bir adamla evlenmiş
mutlu bir aile kur vesaire vesaire Ben
tam tersini söylüyorum başarılı olup da
mutlu olmamak insanın felaketidir Siz
bence Önce mutlu olmayı deneyin Daha
sonra başarılı olmayı dene Teşekkür
ederim sağ ol